Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
This is the way.
This will be my Full Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 1 Video.
There were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references, obviously
setting up a bunch of big stuff.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'll be doing videos for all the episodes
just like I do for all the other seasons.
Be sure to subscribe to get them here
for spoilers from the episode.
If you haven't seen it yet,
we'll start at the beginning
and work our way through Shot by shot.
Talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
starting with the episode title.
It was chapter 17 The Apostate, which is
a reference to Mando in his current state.
He's not considered a mandalorian
by the armor.
The children of the watch as Bo-Katan
calls their sect of Mandalorians,
even though there was a lot of table
setting in this episode
trying to expand the universe
and set up a bunch of big characters
for conflicts later in the season
and continue the overarching plot.
Most of the episode was dedicated
to Mando furthering his quest,
setting that up to redeem himself
by bathing in the living waters
beneath the planet Mandalore
so that he would no longer
be considered an apostate.
They actually started the episode
with a very big recap of the previous
two seasons and the book of Boba Fett
just to set up his quest
at the beginning of season three.
Jon Favreau actually made this funny
YouTube reference to when he said
a lot of people might be picking up
The Mandalorian for the first time
with Season three,
and there's all this plot
that people might have missed
if you didn't watch the Book of Boba Fett.
Like, how did he get the darksaber?
What was going on with Grogu?
Why is Grogu wearing that Beskar
chainmail armor shirt?
And Jon Favreau said, No,
we're not going to worry about that.
We're just going to pick up with the plot.
As if people had watched
the book of Boba Fett,
and if they have questions
they can watch recap videos on YouTube.
What a coincidence that I make
a whole bunch of Mandalorian videos.
They haven't quite run
into a marvel problem with the Star Wars
Mandalorian universe
because it's only a couple spinoff shows,
but eventually
they'll have the same problem too,
where there's like a bunch of different
shows
that you have to watch in order
to keep up on the plot.
For example, there was a big Easter
Egg moment at the beginning of the episode
where they reference the space.
Well, that's actually setting up
a big plot point for the Ahsoka series.
Ezra Bridger in Grand Admiral Thrawn,
which I'll talk about when we get to
that part of the episode,
because it was a really cool Easter egg,
but it was setting up something
much, much bigger.
Later on,
they actually opened the episode
in a slightly different way
too, with the armor creating something,
forging a new piece of armor
for a kid
that had chosen to become Mandalorian.
The whole ceremony at the beginning
is meant to be a metaphor for Din
Jared's journey,
trying to regain his order
because he took that same creed
when he was a little kid.
He went through the same process,
but then took his helmet off.
So now he has to kind of speed run,
do some things to regain his honor
so he can be considered
part of their group.
Again, they didn't explain
which planet she's moved their cover to,
but it's different
from where they were on that space station
during the book of Boba Fett.
You notice
in the background of her workshop,
there's the giant symbol
of the mandalorians.
It's a skull of a myth.
The saw the mythical creature
that was tamed and killed
by the mythical mandalore
that she references during the creed.
This is just meant to be
the standard ceremony
that they give to all children
when they come of a certain age
and take the Mandalorian
Creed to become part of their people.
They put the helmet on
and then never take it off,
except when they're by themselves
or where they need to eat
when they are also by themselves.
Even though they didn't
totally explain this mandalorians do
take their helmets off to get it on.
Like you had to get Mandalorian children
from somewhere.
Some of them are born. Mandalorian.
Some of them they find like Din Djarin.
Married couples can take their helmets off
in their presence,
like they could take their helmet off
in their children's presence too.
But when they're in public,
they always have to wear their helmet.
So it's not like they sleep
in their helmets.
When she recites the creed, she started
talking about the name of the ancestors
that she'll walk the way of Mandalore
that's the name of their ancestral ruler.
Later, rulers of their people
would also use the name as an honorific,
and each leader of their people
would be called Mandalore.
So like at the end of the episode,
when Bogut dances, fine,
you go lead all these people,
go find the mercenaries,
all these different clans,
unite them with the Darksaber
they'll do whatever you say.
If he actually did that,
like he has a claim to the best star
throne of Mandalore,
he would be called Mandalore,
but tens of thousands of years ago,
like a long time ago,
there was an actual mandalore
who then united their people.
He wound up taming myth
the or this giant mythical creature.
And that's why the symbol of all
mandalorians is this myth a sword skull.
They all recite a very big
This is the way.
This is the way. This is the way.
I'm not sure what kind of giant
alligator creature this is.
It seems like it's from the lore.
If you think you know,
right up below in the comments.
But they use this big action scene
as a sort of mirror to the action scene
at the beginning of season two to show you
all these different mandalorians
using their weapons,
their skills to try and take it down.
Like this is what it looks like when
a bunch of mandalorians work together.
The cool thing too is that you see a bunch
of different types of mandalorians too.
Like they're a bunch of mandalorian
females.
There are a bunch of Mandalorian children.
And just as Paz
Vizsla is about to get eaten, Mando swoops
in with his Naboo star
fighter and Grogu Quinto in Save Them.
Remember the big deal here is the past.
Vizsla challenged him for the Darksaber
It sounds like now it's
water under the bridge.
Enough time has passed in the way that Jon
Favreau explained.
It is a grogu who was with Luke Skywalker
for about two years.
So it's been a long while
since the end of season two
and another small time jump
since the book of Boba Fett.
So it's not like he fought past
Vizsla last week or anything like that.
The armor reminds him
why he's an apostate.
There's a lot of that in this episode
with characters
reiterating
what just happened to like sort recaps
from all the different characters
about what
his mission is, what all of them
are trying to do right now
in the timeline,
just because it's been so long
since The Mandalorian Season two.
Like, by the way,
you're not a Mandalorian anymore
because you took your helmet off.
Remember?
We went through that
during the book of Boba Fett,
and he brings her a piece of the planet
found by Jawas
Jar was always a solid source
for really important plot items.
Any time you need something
really important for the plot,
just go buy it from a Jawa.
When she says the surface of Mandalore
was crystallized by fusion race,
that just means the Empire fired
so many weapons on it for so long
it just heated the surface of the planet
up until it turned crystalline.
We seen a little bit of that
in the trailers,
like these crystal looking caves.
That's the surface of Mandalore.
His whole conversation
with her about redemption
is meant to be a metaphor
for all their people, like their people
as a culture,
like all the different clans.
None of them agree with each other,
but they're all looking for redemption.
Then coming together under a single banner
and retaking the planet would be
the culmination of that redemption.
But who knows that that's going to happen
in like season four, season five.
But this is him setting up that arc,
like the whole concept of redemption
for him, for himself,
just to become a mandalorian,
but also for the Mandalorian people
just in general.
So pretty much everyone on the show
is looking for a form of redemption,
but this is mostly about the Mandalorians.
Even Bo-Katan
is looking for some kind of redemption
because the rest of the people
that were following her basically took off
because she doesn't have the darksaber
and they don't care about her anymore.
The armor reluctantly agrees
to let him try to reclaim his order.
Like, okay, fine, go check it out
when he says he'll see her again.
That just means that
we will see the armor again this season.
Then we see a huge Easter egg scene
for something.
Hopefully they'll pay off this season.
Hopefully they don't wait all the way
to the Ahsoka series to pay this off.
Pretty much everybody
was pulling a Leonardo DiCaprio meme
the minute grogu
you look through hyperspace,
know he's just marveling at everything
like this is so cool
and sees the space whales,
the hyperspace is whales,
their race of creatures
who exist in hyperspace
like they live in hyperspace and can
naturally navigate through hyperspace.
They took Ezra Bridger in Grand Admiral
Thrawn in his fleet to the unknown regions
at the end of Star Wars rebels.
I think, you know, early theory
they're showing them here
at the beginning of the season,
just a quick Easter egg moment
to foreshadow the return of both
Ezra Bridger
and Grand Admiral Thrawn with his fleet.
Because remember,
grand Admiral Thrawn is someone that Ahsoka
was looking for during season two,
and he's meant to be the overarching
villain for the big eventual crossover
Avengers Infinity War endgame level
event that they're building up to.
I don't know if we're supposed
to see Grand Admiral Thrawn on screen.
Like, we'll find out who the actor
is during this season
or if they'll wait till the Ahsoka series.
But I do think that we will definitely see
some grand Admiral Thrawn scenes
during the Ahsoka episodes later
this year.
That's not going to air
till like the end of this year though.
But for the most part
the events of that series
will take place around the same time
period that The Mandalorian Season
three is taking place.
We'll probably get some kind of Ahsoka
cameo, maybe a Sabine
Cameo during this season
two just sort of set that up.
But the fact that Grogu
who is seeing the hyperspace
wheels isn't unique to Grogu
who Mando could see them to.
They're not like invisible to people
who aren't force sensitive
or who don't have great Jedi powers
or anything like that.
Anybody with a pair of eyeballs
could see them.
It is not like there's just this one
group, the same group from Star Wars
Rebels.
There's a bunch of them
that exist all over the galaxy,
the Mando Grogu who head back to Navarro,
who grief Karga has taken over.
He's the new high magistrate of the town,
and it's cleaned the place up, basically
dignified in the same way they did was
they like Times Square in New York City.
When he lands in the star
port there, there's an AR five droid
in a white C-3PO unit.
There's a couple different AR five units
that we see.
And one later in his Naboo N-1
one Starfighter.
So when they keep saying
that he needs a droid in Isaiah
11 isn't going to be ready for a while.
I think that one of the droids that he
eventually winds up using is an R5 unit.
I think they just showed
a bunch of R five units
in the background here to foreshadow
that this one off to the right is an EV
99 droid like the one in Jarvis Palace
and the one that had become a bartender
in the most likely cantina
in earlier season,
who is voiced by Mark Hamill
in a stealth cameo.
That was actually Mark
Hamill doing that voice, The Droid
Manhunter.
I'm looking for some work.
Unfortunately, The bounty count
no longer operates from Tatooine.
One of the funny things about Star
Wars is Mark
Hamill said that he's done that a lot,
like a bunch of stealth cameos,
that he was uncredited
for in the history of Star Wars TV series.
He's also done some of the movies, too.
So if you rewatch the movies in the TV
series,
you might pick up in the background.
If you listen really carefully,
like that random character
sounds an awful lot like Mark Hamill.
As they start walking through the streets,
Grogan starts going crazy,
looking at all the different types of food
that they pass by.
The creatures roasting on the spit
seem like womp rats.
I think that's meant to be a reference
to the salacious crumbs
that were roasting in season
one on the spit, because right after this
we see a bunch of them
living wild and free in a tree nearby.
The chef droid is also a super deep cut.
There was one in the Attack of the Clones
novelization and was featured
in some of the other novels as well.
And there was one
during the book of Boba Fett,
even though we didn't see him
in this episode,
I do believe that Boba Fett
is supposed to show up at some point
in some kind of cameo scene.
The bat creature
isn't meant to be a minus.
It looks like a character
from the Jedi Fallen order game,
which is more like a bat
owl kind of hybrid looking creature.
There's a couple familiar aliens,
like there's a man calamari here.
The second white C-3PO droid is acting
more like a tourism advertisement,
which Greef Carga follows up on later.
Just trying to hype up
the local amenities.
Like see how nice it is here.
The basic idea is that they wanted
to turn this into a bigger tourist
destination, a bigger trade hub, so
the planet is just earning way more money.
Now he's way, way richer as he tells
Mando,
This isn't the Cantina band,
but it is another band.
This is the statue of IG 11
who sacrificed himself
to save Mando and Grogu
during season one, voiced by Taika
Waititi that they bring back later
in the episode for a quick joke.
There's a gang droid behind them,
and one later in the episode,
two bunch of gang droids
walking around in time.
There's a bunch of droids on screen
when Greef Karga comes out to meet them,
he's got another three pod type of droid
serving him and two little attendant
droids for keeping his long flowing robes
from catching on the ground.
I'm not sure what kind of droids
these small ones are,
but if you think you know
right up below in the comments
when he mentions the Heidi in a way
that's a super route through the galaxy,
like a major trade route.
So being one of the big hubs on
that is a huge deal for Navarro, meaning
they earn way more money on the trade
that passes through the area.
And there is a lot more trade
passing through the area now.
Greef
Karga tries to get Mando to move back
permanently because he wants the marshal
and wants to keep the planet independent.
But Mando turns him down because of his
quest to become Mandalorian again.
You notice in the background
of his office, there's a bust of himself.
Seems kind of vain, which they also use
for another joke later to crush IG 11
because Greef
Karga is in such great need of a marshal
that also reminds you of the Marshal Cobb
Vanth from Mando Season two,
who has been recovering in Boba
Fett's back the tank for a while now.
Maybe they'll wind up paying that off.
They teased that Cobb
Vanth would come back eventually.
That's why he woke up
at the end of the book of Boba Fett.
Whether that Post-Credits scene like, Oh
yeah, if he's still alive, he'll be back.
You know, this Grogu
who is using the force like a little kid,
would just spin the chair around
and grab some space.
Skittles.
He is meant to be way more powerful
than when he left.
Luke There's been a time jump since
he left Luke Skywalker,
so he's gotten that much more powerful.
And if you didn't notice earlier, zoom
in enhance. He's
actually been wearing the best scarred
chainmail armor that Mando got him.
He wears that pretty much all the time.
Now. He'll probably wear that pretty much
all the time in future episodes, too.
They name brought the Pirate King
Glory shard.
He isn't someone from Star Wars
before this that I could detect.
I believe they created the character new
for the series,
just like a new antagonist
in this part of space.
He's meant to be a higher level pirate.
The Greek cargo used to do business
with this pirate group works for the way
the Greek carga talks about him.
Sounds like they want to set him up
as a major antagonist,
like even though he doesn't get Mando.
During this episode,
they just set up the idea that he's
going to be really pissed off at Mando
and probably come back for revenge
eventually.
They have a gunslinger standoff
to show you how he hasn't lost his edge,
even though he's kind of dignified.
NAVARRO Greef Carga shot
first hand versus Greedo reference.
Mando kills the other pirates, setting up
the conflict later with the pirate king.
And then they use this moment to explain
what happened to Cara Dune
after the big dustup that Gina Carano had
with Disney where they fired her.
Basically, this is actually pretty crazy
when it was going down
a couple of years ago.
If you actually remember,
they were developing a full blown spinoff
show for Cara Dune's character
called the Rangers of the New Republic.
When she got into trouble with Disney
and they fired her,
they basically canceled that.
But here's the thing.
Jon Favreau and Dave Filoni said
that they're not writing
the character off the show.
They're not killing her off.
They explained that she's in another
part of the galaxy with the New Republic
Special Forces until further notice, quote
unquote, implying that Gina Carano
and Disney will eventually make nice
and she'll come back to the show.
Within the world of TV and movies,
if you know a character's
never coming back,
they use them for some grisly offscreen
death.
Like they would have done that
if she was never going to come back.
So I think that she will eventually
come back.
They explained
what happened to Moff Gideon
after the end of Mandalorian season two.
They took it to a New Republic
War tribunal.
He will be back again
later this season and he's supposed to get
a really cool, Mandalorian
inspired Beskar version of his armor.
I think he said that there's
going to be a big rally for his character
this season, but he's tied up with what
grand Admiral Thrawn is doing,
which is a much bigger deal
that the pretties later this season.
But at least right now
when Mando is talking to greet Karga,
it sounds like Moff Gideon
is still a prisoner of the New Republic.
So at some point during the season
someone is going to have to break him out,
Greef Karga explains to Mando
how he's trying to keep Navarro
as independent as possible in the outer
rim from the New Republic.
Any other governmental force,
like the remnants of the old Empire,
the huts, any of the other major
corporate interests in the galaxy.
So that's why he doesn't want another
New Republic soldier to be as marshal in
why I think they're setting up Cobb Vanth
maybe to be his marshal.
The whole joke about Mando
wanting to revive IG 11
is that he needs a droid to help him
explore Mandalore and he used to hate
droids like it was a big thing
in the first season.
IG 11 wound up being one of the only ones
that he came to like in trust.
They use it mostly for a funny moment,
like they bring Taika Waititi back
for a really quick blink
and you'll miss a cameo scene
who reverts to his former programing,
trying to kill Grogu with them playing
hot potato with Grogu.
Do they just throw him around the room
like a little football?
I'm sure Grogu
who is used to it at this point
and he probably uses the force to cushion
some of those blows.
His protocol
droid winds up using his very vain
bust to crush him
when they're going to get him fixed.
Mando uses a new slang term,
or at least the first time
I've heard the slang term Scud,
the other major slang word that he started
using these past couple of seasons
in on the book of Boba Fett
is basically like the Star Wars
version of the F bomb.
They reveal the expert droid Smiths living
in the area are from Baboo for x rays.
Now it's not the same Babu
Fricke from Star Wars.
The rise of Skywalker is much later
in the timeline.
This is just from their race.
Their official name is the Ends Zealands.
There's a whole bunch of other Droid parts
in the background.
If you think you've spotted
some Easter eggs
right them below in the comments
and he vows to find another memory unit
so that they can completely revive IG 11
and he'll start working again.
We'll see if they pay that off later
this season
when they're leaving the planet again,
they show another R5 droid,
another gang droid.
I think just to foreshadow
that Mando will temporarily
eventually use an R five unit
and Grogu will ride in the pod with him.
Here's
another big foreshadowing moment too.
So he teaches Grogu
how to navigate in hyperspace.
That will probably come in
handy later this season.
In future seasons,
it's probably foreshadowing that
Grogu will have to travel on his own
for some reason,
even though he's so small,
it would kind of be hard for him
to crawl up and push all the buttons
to navigate through Hyperspace Lane
and his pirate group attack to retaliate
for killing the other pirates.
Not sure what kind of fighters
they're using.
I believe these are from the Clone Wars.
Most of the fighters
that you see in in the series
so far are from the prequel era.
They have a much bigger dogfight
than they've had in previous seasons
in the asteroids.
Any time there's a dogfight,
an asteroids in the Star Wars universe,
it just reminds me of Empire Strikes
Back with the asteroid field in Attack
of the Clones with Obi-Wan in Jango Fett.
For the most part,
they use this big action scene
just to show you how much better
their special effects have gotten.
Like it's a much bigger asteroid fight
than we've seen in previous seasons.
Grogu having the time of his life.
They reveal Gory in Shard, the pirate
captain has a much larger cruiser.
It's not quite as big as Moff Gideon's
cruiser, but it's still pretty big.
And I couldn't tell what race he is
or find a reference to him in the canon,
so he might be a totally new creature that
they haven't done before in Star Wars.
He reminds me of a version of Swamp Thing
from the DC Universe
mixed with Davy Jones
from Pirates of the Caribbean.
And like I said earlier,
I think they're setting him up
as a bigger antagonist for later
this season, in future seasons.
Then they travel to
the Mandalorian system, where the planet
Mandalore is to the planet Kavala,
where Boka Tanz group of Mandalorians
has been living, even though,
according to Bo-Katan,
there's not that many of them
living with her at the moment.
But they just want to let you know
this is very near to the actual planet.
Mandalore
like he's very near to their homeworld.
This Mandalorian castle is designed
in the traditional Mandalorian style
of architecture with Bo-Katan throne
looking similar to the throne room
on Mandalore not quite
the same as it was during the Clone Wars
and Rebels, but pretty close to her throne
room is much smaller.
The throne room that you saw on the actual
planet Mandalore is way, way bigger.
I'm not sure
what kind of protocol droid this is,
but I believe it's also from the Clone
Wars.
The symbol on all of her
banners are for Bo-Katan is night owls.
Then this mural is sitting right
next to her.
Like back on the wall
is meant to be a huge Easter egg
reference to the Mandalorian.
Civil Wars is meant to be a huge metaphor
on the show for the way all the different
factions, the mandalorians like Bo-Katan
group, the armors group,
the other separate group that took off
when she didn't have the Darksaber.
None of them agree with each other.
They're a fractured people
in need of someone,
someone with a darksaber,
maybe someone named Mando in Grogu
to unite them because Bo-Katan
very literally challenges him with that.
Like why don't you go lead them, take
the darksaber they'll do anything you say.
She explains what happened to her after
the end of the Mandalorian Season two.
She says all her former supporters
amongst the Mandalorian clans left her
after she returned without the Darksaber
and all the Empire ships that she had
stolen with them turned to mercenary
work in the interim just to earn money.
So there's a whole bunch of mandalorians
out there
with a whole bunch of capital ships
just waiting for someone to unite them,
someone with the darksaber.
But first things first, Mando
has to reclaim his honor
so that the Armor's
people will accept him.
So the whole idea here is
that Mando is getting the support
of all these different
Mandalorian clans slowly.
It is going to take a little while
when she tells him
to go to the Civic Center beneath Sundari.
That's the main Mandalorian city,
the dome city that we saw
during the Clone Wars and Star Wars
Rebels.
We went there a bunch of times on
both shows.
It's basically
the capital of the Mandalore planet
where the main throne room is.
So when he goes there in episode two,
it sounds like we might see a live action
version of the throne room, the place
where he needs to go in those tunnels
is the same area where a soldier went
at the end of the Clone Wars.
We'll get more with Bo-Katan
I think, in episode to episode three,
because you see footage of them
from scenes
in the trailers
with them standing together and grogu.
So she might also go back to the planet
Mandalore with him.
She also recaps the brief history
of their people before
and after the Purge,
claiming that his group, the armors group
which she calls the watch,
fractured their people.
And I think what
they're trying to imply here
is that Bo-Katan believes that they left
the Mandalorians vulnerable to the Empire
and had that not happened,
they could have withstood the purge
or they could have prevented it
from happening in the first place.
So the idea here is that Bo-Katan
kind of hates the armor
because she thinks that them
turning to the traditional hardcore ways
of living and leaving, like being exiled
to the moon near Mandalore
fractured their people, weakening them
in on the other side of things.
The armor we know hates Bo-Katan
because she views her as a weak leader
and a pretender to the throne.
Amanda Lure
because she doesn't have the darksaber.
She also tells Mando
she doesn't believe in
any of the mumbo jumbo
that he's talking about.
These living waters beneath Mandalore.
It's all just a bunch of hooey.
Doesn't mean anything.
It's meant to give you vibes of Han
Solo during a new hope.
When Obi-Wan Kenobi and Luke Skywalker
started talking about the force here.
I've flown from one side of this galaxy
to the other.
I've seen a lot of strange stuff,
but I've never seen anything
to make me believe.
There's one
all powerful force controlling everything.
So one of a couple of things
could wind up happening here.
I think he's going to make a believer
out of Bo-Katan.
He'll find something on the planet
that will make her believe,
and she'll start to slowly
come around to his line of thinking.
And obviously
the armor will start to like him again
because he will fulfill his quest
to regain his order so slowly.
The idea
is that by the time we get to season
four, season five, how many seasons
the show runs, all the different
Mandalorians will start to believe in him
as a good leader.
They don't really get into a lot
of what's going on with Grogu
during this episode
because it's
mostly about Mando in his quest,
but I think they'll get into that
in future episodes.
The whole idea that Grogu,
who is also meant to be
the next Mandalorian Jedi or something
close to it
because he left Luke Skywalker's
Jedi Academy.
So technically he's not a Jedi.
He's pursuing his own path
through the force.
Kind of like a soldier is
like a soldier is a very learned Jedi,
but technically she is not a Jedi.
She left the Jedi Order right now.
You just think of her
as a very powerful force user.
So that's kind of
what's going on with Grogu.
But because being a Mandalorian isn't
about being born a mandalorian, it's
more about taking the creed like Din
Djarin was not born Amanda Laurean,
but the whole idea is that the Darksaber
is meant to be the sort of nexus
between Mandalorian and Jedi culture.
That's also grogu, whose character as
well Grogu, who is both a Jedi
oriented character
like he's from that world,
but he's also slowly becoming
a Mandalorian like Mando.
Now, everybody
wondering if Grogu is ever going to wield
the Darksaber Wouldn't that be cool?
His tiny little hands
probably wouldn't be big enough
to wrap around the hilt,
but he could use the force to wield it.
Maybe Mando can make a tiny Yoda sized
darksaber Overall, it was a great episode.
It feels like it was a big course
correction too.
Like them going back to basics.
So I'm really excited to see where
the rest of the season goes.
If you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
I'll do an episode two trailer video next
in my full episode two video we'll post
next week after they release it, everyone
click here for that episode two video.
Update the link as soon as I posted
and click here to learn why
Grogu left Luke Skywalker's
Jedi Academy so fast.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
And this is the way.